he's a cheater who failed when his
gender was unveiled we speak of the
chess playing Jerka who hid inside
a burka
Jerka we had to make the word up yeah
it's not our fault they use a term that
has no rhyme burka
really hurts people like me and
internationally rated male chess player
in Kenya has been busted disguising
himself as a woman
on the right there to compete in the
women's division
talk about cheating what does he think
this is a woman's swim meet
[Applause]
the Kenya open Chess Championship held
earlier this week offered prize money
totally 42 Grand while it's no Bud Light
sponsorship it's still a decent Payday
for cross-dressing nerds and that's what
piqued the interest of a young
cash-strapped college kid the fraudster
hit his identity by wearing a nikob
registering under a fake name and never
talking which is what I do whenever I'm
checking in at the Marriott Express
that and I tell them the frightened
young man I'm traveling with is my
nephew
but you're leaving alone the next
morning ah shut up but does the disguise
worked he was able to fool his
competitors and even tournament staff
suspicions only Rose after he beat
uganda's top female chess player at
which point he was investigated and
finally gave up the ruse now we're not
sure if this story is a scandal among
native Kenyans and we haven't heard back
yet from Barack Obama
and on his conspiracy frequency
the cheater has since it been expelled
from the tournament and no one knows
what his next move will be
as winnings are long gone but on the
bright side he got five marriage
proposals from the Taliban
and playing as a queen he can always go
back to beating the bishop
yo took me a second I got it
I'm sorry Tulsi for the second time
this is the most difficult question
what does it say when some no-name dude
in a dress beats the country's best
female player what's that say I'll let
you answer that my question is when I
saw this story was can you imagine what
would happen if that happened here in
the United States why didn't he identify
as trans well I mean you know I mean
look you look at what he's wearing you
look at how he's identifying right you
look at this woke culture in our own
Society people would be silent and he
would be walking away with the winning
the winning the winning cash exactly
yeah he was he was in America they would
have been on his side and he all he
would have to say is that he's a she
listen I I need to sit the brother down
and explain things to them how it works
see where he went wrong was he tried to
still be a man see and that's what you
and I talked about in the back men have
consequences for their actions now if he
would have identified a woman he
wouldn't even need the costume that's
true he could have grew his beard out
like mine and be like what up girls I'm
here yes I identify as and no one can
say anything but he wanted to be
arrogant and still be a man you can't
have it both ways bro yeah okay if you
want to play in the girl Sports you got
to identify as a woman that's the only
fair way to do it exactly
yeah it's so funny that was literally
the stupidest thing I've ever said in my
life
yeah
it's it's such it's so true he's he he's
behind the times he should have just he
should have just said he was a woman and
he wouldn't have to wear the Burke at
all what an idiot
stupid Canyon
that's not racist no
he is Kenyan and he's stupid
hence well he did beat the world
okay smart I'm just gonna stop Tulsi
didn't answer the question what does it
say with some no-name college dude
Pete's the world champion female Kenyan
in chess what's that say I can answer
that yes so I think men are probably
better at chess than women but here's
why because women are more more
emotionally intelligent than men are so
it's less likely for us to wind up with
the kind of social life that would force
us to resort to competitive just
you're right yeah yeah that's good it's
a good good call there thank you
yeah that's the way most girls play
checkers
proof that your emotional
[Laughter]
emotional to another human being let
alone on camera
your safe word is Yahtzee
it makes no sense I don't even know why
I said that finish it by saying a sexist
would say that sexist would say we'll
drop that in post
I mean I think first of all I don't
think trans is a thing in Kenya no it's
not you know it's not really a thing so
I don't think he had the option because
we have not yet exported our nonsense on
that front to Kenya you did so true
we're the ones that pushing are pushing
and peddling this stuff all around the
world do you remember how we and I mean
we as in Fox would like or what are the
talking points or so is we don't want to
be like Europe like we're good they're
turning us into Europe as a social as a
socialist State who knew that we I kind
of wish we were Europe because they're
not crazy no I'm pretty sure I said that
a hundred times yeah they're not crazy I
know it's like now it's like the
Europeans are like looking at us going
what the hell happened and we're looking
at ourselves and I'm going wait okay are
we the bad guy yeah yeah
because we're the ones pushing other
countries to obsess to go backwards in
the name of climate change and forwards
in the name of child mutilation remember
remember when we would go go after
Muslims for female circumcision remember
that what are we doing now female
genital mutilation exactly it's like
we're like it's it's a it's kind of
scary and sobering at the same time well
I think that's it for today's show
we have a whole another half
up next with a constant smile postponed
going senile hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else